ladies and gentlemen welcome back to the
channel look you know we we talk about
con men of all time con women
of all time quite frankly equal
opportunity for everybody and today
you guys are gonna absolutely die about
this i'm late to the story to be honest
but it's
so good that i decided i'd cover it
anyways uh basically
youtube won a free speech award
sponsored by youtube
what what is this world cup to let's go
to the board i gotta show you guys this
welcome ladies and gentlemen to the 10
million dollar studio i'm
your host coffee coffeezilla and yes
we're talking about youtube today listen
i love youtube they do a lot of great
things you can say a lot of positive
things about them
freedom of speech just ain't one of them
right like
giving people a platform uh you know for
entertainment
making silly goofy videos like this
right it's like saying look
what's facebook good for it's good for
grandma right connecting with grandma it
has things that it does
but if you gave mark zuckerberg a
privacy award you'd be an idiot because
every time you log in
like 20 russians get sold your
information everybody knows it right
it's like giving
edward snowden you know a secret keeping
award it's just not what he does
so when you give youtube a freedom of
speech award everyone was like
what what are you talking about this
freedom of expression award
that they won from this freedom
foundation or something like that
and then you go and you find out they
sponsored the whole thing
they're the signature sponsor so susan's
here like saying like
i'm honored i'm you know all this you
paid for it so
what is this award it's called the free
expression awards they've been doing it
for a while but listen to
their own description of what their
reward is the free expression awards
recognize
those who exhibit passion and dedication
to free expression including those
who have taken personal or professional
risks in sharing information with the
public
are censored or punished by authorities
or groups for sharing their work
or show courage by pushing boundaries in
artistic
and media expression ladies and
gentlemen youtube
has done none of these things so the
whole point of these awards is what you
think like it's like
people who take risks you know one of
the winners is julia k brown the person
who exposed like the epstein thing right
one of the big
team reporters she deserves the win
soojin wojcicki
this lady is like one of the people
cracking down on people
i mean i think you'd win an award from
fighting you know with youtube about
censorship or something like that
not from being the corporate behemoth
that censors a bunch of people
and yes i am biting the hand that feeds
me and it is probably a mistake
i mean you cannot make this stuff up
it's too funny not to cover
look at that look in the video which is
supposed to be celebrating
free speech right but the first thing
they talk about is the fact that
they're removing content and that's the
reason they're getting this award check
this out it's amazing dude it's
incredible
and that has been my number one priority
we're removing content that violates our
policies
the number one priority is removing
stuff
and that's who you gave the free speech
award to
look the dislikes in this thing are
brutal i mean look you can't even see
the like to dislike ratio but don't
worry you won't be able to see the
dislikes soon so don't worry about this
youtube
so yeah they make this video first thing
they talk about is removing
and then they don't stop if i summoned
into these four different r's
the first one would be remove which is
that we're always updating our policies
and when content is violative of
of any of the policies unfortunately we
need to remove it so we removed nine
million videos
last quarter and almost all of them over
ninety percent we were
removed with machines nine million
videos and this is what you choose
to talk about during your free speech
award acceptance you're like look
look how many we got rid of and they're
all machines we've created a machine
state we're removing videos
automatically
how could this possibly be something you
talk about
at least hide it have the decency like
let's say you give bp oil
you know a green a climate award you
wouldn't expect them to talk about their
biggest oil spill
during the acceptance of that award like
at least have the tact
to understand where you are and be like
look hey we would never like just lie
right just lie
instead it's like first thing up on our
plan
remove it's like giving ggp a a
humanitarian award and the first thing
he says is like
the way i've created peace in my society
is with the four eyes
the first eye being internment camp and
you're like okay wait
back up this is so weird man it's such a
bizarre
thing to be watching it's mostly like
right wingers that have been covering
this but
it's everybody that's being affected
which is why i'm talking about it
because this show is not political but
everyone is affected by this not just a
guy on
one side of the political spectrum or
the other you guys need to understand
that you should care about this issue of
free speech like real free speech
regardless
of where you sit on the fence she talks
about something called borderline
content
it's borderline and so for that content
we'll just reduce meaning we're not
going to recommend it
to our users it's still on the platform
but it's content
that is not necessarily recommended by
our platform
i love this dude this is actually my
favorite part of the whole thing
and i think she deserves some kind of
kind of an award for this performance
how can you say with a straight face
look it's on our platform we just don't
recommend it when your whole platform is
a recommendation algorithm
it's like netflix being like yeah it's
in our catalog we just never show it to
anybody
it's like wait this this makes those
this is why you guys should care though
look left right sitter whatever
apolitical you should care about this
issue
of borderline content and youtube
producing it because this is one of the
most frustrating things of the creator
is we can't talk about anything dude
i make stories all the time i say i
can't run it nobody's going to see it
it's not
it's going to be demonetized even
there's this new thing they don't even
recommend the content to the people who
want to see it
look so a few examples of people who are
not on the right talking about this
because i feel like it's only people on
the right talking about it i don't want
to just
go from that perspective so here's david
pakman talking about borderline content
for a second now the terms we have to
interpret
are borderline content and what it means
that youtube claims that they
are succeeding that their policy is
working
to stifle borderline content because
when they talk about borderline content
it's not just white nationalist stuff
it's not just hate speech
it's all the independent news content
like our channel
that gets wrapped up with the hate
content and not recommended and it
crushes us
when youtube now says that this is
working
what they mean is the algorithm changes
they've made
are correctly recommending corporate
content over hours
and it's a disaster that's absolutely
right like content just gets tagged
borderline you have no way
of knowing that and you have no way of
correcting or appealing that
and then you don't get recommended to
anyone and look philip defranco says the
same thing check it out
but suppressing the flow of news
coverage suppressing the flow
of information isn't the answer this
isn't a you cracking down on
misinformation story or situation this
is you
looking at news coverage of going that's
too mature for everybody but that's the
world out there right now that's how you
scare people away from trying to keep
those
in power accountable if people know
you're going to kill their video and
you're
killing videos because they're talking
about serious accusations
how can you hold people accountable
people are just not going to bring to
light
serious stories that's right look this
is youtube's golden boy dude there's no
one
youtube's a bigger fan of than philip
defranco and he's out here saying look
even my show isn't corporate enough
for youtube even my show i can't even do
my show
because about certain topics because i
know youtube's not gonna run with it
this is like
the most non-controversial creator ever
saying i have to censor myself
so the irony of youtube coming on and
being like look guys
hey free speech award and the first
thing they talk about is removing
content censoring content it's like
how does this ever get aired because
again you can say a lot of positive
things about
the way they've led their company it's
become very monetarily successful right
people do very well with you know
running ads all that running entire
media corporations
like linus tech tips or a philip
defranco show or you know all these big
like almost corporate shows now that's
great but you can't say they're a free
speech platform i would say that this is
one of the dumbest things i've ever seen
and i just wanted to call a little bit
of attention to it because i love
youtube as a platform
but i wish they would do more for free
speech instead of this
whole game where they're trying to you
know i guess project
giving themselves an award and hoping
all of us believe it
but uh yeah i i just wanted to talk
about this i hope this issue matters to
you guys it matters to me i mean i'm
just waiting for the day
that they cracked out on my channel it's
inevitable the kind of stuff we talk
about but
it is really sad that youtube can just
pay for an award like that
this you would think that you would have
to earn it but yeah i don't know let me
know what you guys think do you think
they deserve this award
back to the regular kind of content
tomorrow we talk about fakers of all
kind though not just the people
lying to you about a harvard speech but
the people lying to you about a free
speech award but that's basically it
thanks for watching
see you next time
wake up and smell the coffee